welcome everyone welcome thank you for
joining today's webinar
now on the webinar i'm sure we all come
from different experience levels with
lean six sigma uh those of us that are
just being introduced to it for the
first time and those of us that maybe
have been practitioners for a while we
just like to
keep our skills sharp and just to
learn about different things right so
some of you would be able to
present this webinar as well so
but this is just like we would see an
introduction to lean six sigma talking
about how can improve productivity but i
do hope that in the future as we go
through this webinar and go through the
materials i really do like what our host
was sharing with you that i do enjoy
teaching in in sharing about the
principles of lean six sigma
and seeing how that applies to what you
do so hopefully sometime in the future
we're able to connect and i can see what
you do and help apply the lean six sigma
principles even more than we're going to
present here
right how it's about a key to
productivity
so this is a little bit about me
right of course i'm a lean success
practitioner and trainer i have my black
belt certification through asq
i've seen six sigma applied in many
different areas
a manufacturing i.t supply chain
different job titles but the one that i
enjoy is being a student of each and
every one of you learning
how to see to make businesses successful
i've been teaching with something
learned for a long time
and i i enjoy six sigma but i also enjoy
leadership
so i don't have to spend much time about
myself let's jump right into uh the
lesson
that we have here so as we're talking
about productivity there are certain
principles that we need to be aware of
in regards to lean six sigma
and we're talking about principles and
not prince of poles
but they're very important that we need
to understand what's going on
and these principles are the key behind
success these are the key to unlock the
productivity
so a principle is a fundamental truth or
a proposition that serves as the
foundation for a system
a belief or behavior for a chain of
reasoning
or could this be a fundamental source or
basis for something right so our
principles guide how we think how we
operate
everything about our choice of actions
so the same thing would be true from the
lean six sigma perspective there are
certain principles that guide that make
lean six sigma what it is and those are
the key to unlocking productivity and so
i'm going to present to you today are
several of those principles
as we talked since we're talking about
productivity of lean six sigma
so there are other well-known principles
out there
in the world we have the bernoulli
principles
about how the air
over going over a wing and the air under
the wing the difference in the speed of
the air moving over a wing causes lift
and that's how we have airplanes and we
have flight
it's based off of a principle there
it's a truth we have archimedes
principle
you can see here on the slide archimedes
principle about that's about buoyancy
and how our ships and how things stay
afloat how water
forces has a pressure forcing up on
things that go into it
we have a pareto principle
this may be one that many of you are
aware of in the realm of lean six sigma
or maybe you're not aware of that the
pareto principle
the 80 20 rule
80 of the effort expended
is due to twenty percent of the
individuals or twenty percent of the
causes
uh pareto principle was originally
discovered when looking at the world's
wealth that eighty percent of the wealth
was owned by twenty percent of the
population and since then that principle
was then expanded and applied to many
different
other things and industries
and so these are principles these are
key truths that have been discovered
already existing but they have been
discovered
by bright individuals over the years so
the same thing is true we're talking
about lean six sigma uh that these are
just truths that were already in
existence and that lean six segment is
brought uh together so there's as you
might have heard the expression there's
nothing really new under the sun
lean six sigma didn't really create
something that was revolutionary
in nature
it brought what was already there
how things work how processes should be
looked at how we should go after
continuous improvement it brought under
one umbrella and we have lean six sigma
so we're going to walk through some of
the principles behind it
and just for the time that we have here
we're going to go through four of these
key principles that unlock the key to
productivity
of lean six sigma one is quality
we're gonna get domain
data driven and being a change agent
so we have an emphasis on quality
six sigma follows a rigorous
methodology known as domain it makes
sense for a defined measure analyze and
proven control
number three
decision making is made
and is comprised
is based on data and statistical
analysis
and lastly number four being in a change
agent is critical
and this is just from my own personal
experience
this is not something that you know you
might go to a seminar and hear something
else
from a different quality individual or
someone with their own experience
but for me
working in these different industries
seeing lean six ml applied i've seen
that quality is critical of course the
following a particular process using
data and
being an agent of change we're gonna
break uh break down each of these in
some more detail as we go throughout
so principle number one emphasis on
quality
and how it is quality unlocking
productivity but the first question we
need to answer is what is quality
so henry ford is known as saying that
quality means doing it right when no one
is looking
steve jobs says that quality is more
important than quantity one home run is
much better than two doubles and so
there are various definitions of what we
mean by quality
but at the end of the day
what i want to know is what is quality
to you
think about we're all we're all
consumers we're all customers to some
product or some service and so we have
an idea of what quality means and that
is what's critical that's when i pose
that question we look at from a lean six
sigma perspective
uh the principle of how it helps us
unlock productivity
is we're focused on the customer
so we've all been
uh experienced buying maybe it's your
favorite
candy
whether it's chocolate m ms peanut m ms
the
the plain m ms or the peanut butter
i think we all maybe have experienced a
bag of m m's or whatever your favorite
candy is now from that level there are
probably smaller things we would expect
we don't have a lot of requirements when
it comes to candy if i have a bag of m
ms yes i don't want any
foreign objects in my bag of candy if i
have peanut m ms i want to make sure
that each m m has a peanut inside of it
and if that's not the case if i don't
see that i would be disappointed that'd
be in my mind low quality
now because that's a lower purchase it's
harder for us probably to identify
what's quality and what's not
but for a more expensive purchase like a
vehicle for instance
uh a car or a home or an apartment
whatever it is that we may be purchasing
at a higher level the higher cost to us
it's probably easier to think of what
we're looking for
all right
with the car there are certain features
that we may want you know power lock
power windows obviously in some areas
air conditioning
miles per gallon and those would be
things that detect the quality of the
vehicle for us
and so quality comes from that customer
perspective and that's key when we're
talking about productivity
because we need to understand what's
going on in our processes that's going
to impact providing that quality to the
customer right not from our business
perspective but from that customer
perspective
so in six sigma quality is simply
defined
as our ability to adhere to customers
requirements
simply put
and so here i also enjoy a good cup of
coffee and so we're going to talk about
quality in terms of a cup of coffee so
let's say the desired temperature of a
cup of coffee is between 160 degrees
fahrenheit
and 180 degrees fahrenheit that
specification we call that would be
quality that's our desired quality level
or a customer requirement
so here we're looking at a particular
process this is a
frequency distribution that's called the
normal distribution won't get into all
the details of that now but let's just
say we go to your favorite coffee
establishment we collect 100 cups of
coffee and we're going to measure the
temperature right right when it comes
out what's the temperature that cup of
coffee because we know as a customer we
like our cup of coffee between 160
degrees fahrenheit and 180 degrees so
for every cup of coffee we're going to
take a measurement and we'll plot it on
this graph so the higher the the value
of this curve that means we observed
more cups of coffee so the our average a
majority of the cups of coffee that we
observed was at 170 degrees fahrenheit
we did observe a few that fell outside
or that was colder than we liked
and we did have some that was a hotter
than we had intended
and so quality is again our ability to
adhere to our customers requirements
this would indicate
poor process capability
for us
now using lean and six sigma we're going
to try to reduce
that
variation in the process
so that we have a higher level of
quality now we see that when we go back
and we measure this information that
there are no cups of coffee
there we don't have any relatively that
are outside
of the customer's expectations we don't
have any that are too cold and we don't
have any that are too hot so this is an
example of excellent process capability
and it's all based off what the customer
has asked which allows us to be more
productive more productive and so at the
end of the day what we were left with
and we're left with a
a customer who is very happy right the
one on the left
some customers will get coffee that's
right in the right temperature and
others won't so you never know what day
of the week to go in for coffee or what
time of the day or what's going to
happen on the one on the left the one on
the right we have consistency our
customers will get a consistent
temperature for their cup of coffee and
be satisfied if that is their
one of their customers requirements of
course that's just one when we go for a
cup of coffee there are several things
that we may like right the sweetness the
flavor but this is just an example
looking at the temperature for that cup
of coffee so principle one is about
quality
so the activities in six sigma are
designed to take us in our organizations
to higher levels of quality which in
turn goes to productivity
and what i want you to know
if you never heard this before about six
sigma when we're talking about that
level of quality
this gives us to a lot of productivity
when you think about productivity it's
doing things effectively right doing
things efficiently at a six sigma level
that means we only have 3.4 defects per
million opportunities
in relation
to our example about cups of coffee that
means out of one million cups of coffee
only three
roughly 3.4 of them
right did not meet the customer uh the
temperature requirements
out of one million think about that
think about how much more productive we
can be at a level of six sigma and that
type of level of quality
right out of everything we produce most
of that is going to providing the
customer what they want
our resources and the investment go to
giving the customer what they need
versus us using that that money and that
time to rework to remake things to throw
things out as scrap and as defective
that's a lot of productivity right there
3.4 defects per million opportunities at
that level of six sigma quality that's
principle one number one uh principle
number two uh six sigma follows domain
uh we consider demand to be our
methodology to get
uh
six sigma and lean complete
so it's pronounced domain
so it's a process six segment
practitioners follow to reduce
variability in their business with the
use of specific tools
now this is something definitely for our
amount of time not enough
time to even go through all the details
of it all but it is it follows define
measure analyze improvement control
what we do here
i'm going to walk through these in a
little bit of detail but definitely
more training would be needed to
understand and unpack the tools involved
but by following a methodology it allows
us to be consistent in how we do
continuous improvement which also in
turn allows us to be more productive
so the defined phase this is the first
step in the demaio cycle
define is about simply documenting the
problem and our desired outcome
this is about having a project charter
scoping off the project having
objectives
deciding what is it that we're going to
measure what's our
what is the customer wanting in the
first place right is it if it's having a
cup of coffee at the right temperature
then why are we not doing that and let's
figure out what's happening in our
process to fix it
so this is the defined phase about
documenting the problem and the desired
outcome
measure when obtaining baseline process
performance levels right collect as much
data as we can on the current process so
that we have an understanding of our
opportunities may lie where are the
issues coming from
is it
is it how long we're we're burning sorry
you know having the coffee on the on the
on the heater on the burner uh the
ingredients we're using
what is causing our our problem so
here's just getting an understanding of
cart performance levels in the measure
phase
three is analyze
analyze is about identifying those key
process
root causes for variation what factors
what elements in the process is causing
it to vary that we're not able to get a
consistent temperature of a cup of
coffee
that's the purpose of analyze to get to
a root cause as we walk through these
steps in demand
if you're familiar with other continuous
improvement methodologies they may sound
familiar whether it might sound familiar
if you're like the pdca cycle plan do
check act
if you're just familiar with the lean
pieces by itself like root cause
analysis that's why i'm saying there's
really nothing new under the sun there's
a different way of looking at things but
six sigma and lean lean six sigmas
combine
different principles into one under one
umbrella
the different structure
improve
the fourth phase in the domain cycle
we wanted to develop tests and implement
solutions
now that we have an understanding after
the analyze phase where our root cause
is and what factors could be impacting
us
let's go and improve it we got to be
creative here
we need creative minds to help us come
up with solutions always beneficial
and then lastly
step five is control we're going to
monitor key factors and maintain the
gains
here is an example of a typical control
tool this is called a control chart
of which
right now definitely won't you won't
becoming an expert and using this tool
if you have not seen it before but i at
least wanted you to get an understanding
of some of the tools that we that's used
in the realm of lean six sigma to help
us improve and increase productivity
right a control chart is very useful and
that's seeing and monitoring the process
to make sure that
the variation stays at a minimum
that we're able to consistently get our
customer what they need and this helps
us identify if something unique has
occurred that we need to go investigate
in the process
principle number three
that six sigma is based on data driven
decision making
and we've all probably been about uh
been a part of different organizations
that make decisions in different ways
whether it's based off of someone's
experience based off of opinion
and what i've seen more often than not
uh when it's just based off an
experience and opinion it can cost us
productivity right sometimes that
individual is right i found many times
that they are not as correct as they
would think
we always
for many of us we think we understand
what's going on in our processes
especially if we've been around it long
enough uh but it's quite interesting
when we pull data and what the data is
telling us right data
removes and at least it it helps us
remove any bias that we may have if we
think our process is the most wonderful
process in the world uh the data is
going to show us the true numbers right
and yes data can be manipulated well
that is a possibility but that's why we
want to train you as a lean six sigma
practitioner to make sure we can
interpret data correctly
but principle number three is that six
sigma is a data driven
decision making process
we want to try to find out what's really
important to our customers
how well are
how well are we meeting customers needs
what elements of our process should we
focus on to better meet customers needs
the data can help drive us to the right
decision and that's why i like this
illustration here there's so many roads
we can go down
but data will help make our path clear
and our path straight
is another key to unlocking productivity
for us
individually in what we do and as a
organization as a whole
so i like this here you might have seen
this before so when you need to make a
hard decision flip a coin why because
when that coin is in the air you
suddenly know what you're hoping for
that is not the approach that's good for
life in some cases
right if we need to make a decision
we're on the fence oh we don't know if
we want to go out to dinner or stay in
home and watch a movie if we flip a coin
the one that we're hoping for that's the
thing that we should probably do that is
not how we want to run an organization
or business however
we want to make decisions based on data
and not on opinions hopes and wishful
thinking
i was saying earlier about making sure
we're using great data so let's clarify
a little bit not every data
not every piece of information is made
equally so make sure that the data is
reliable
i like these uh dilbert cartoons
especially especially the ones in
regards to six sigma very fun i hear it
he's talking about can kind of read the
cartoon here so i'd like to thank all of
the people who helped design the
technology test parameters uh thanks to
your input the test had nothing in
common with how things work in the real
world
so i wasted two weeks of my life on a
test that is not only meaningless but
also dangerously misleading
this slide shows the gap between the
test results and reality
and then his manager is saying we'll use
the test results anyway because it's the
only data we have
and then he goes on saying fine i hope
you all choked to death on your lunches
and i wonder why he's so cranky that's
something about the data i think we've
maybe been part of that situation where
data sometimes does not reflect reality
and our own six sigma we do not want to
use that data at all
that is not the case that's bad uh data
analysis
there so we want to make sure that the
data is reliable that it does in fact
reflect reality and that's another key
principle to help us unlock that
productivity in our organizations
you know we we do talk about there's
some tools and techniques selling six
sigma that help us make sure our data is
reliable
one of those is called like an msa a
measurement system analysis
also the data should not be used to push
an agenda
here we have
a chief station for a company
that's saying i can prove or disprove it
what do you want me to do
so data can be manipulated i think we've
all heard of things that make us cringe
about data or whether it's the
toothpaste commercial that is telling us
that three out of four doctors approve
or three out of four dentists approve
this or approve that uh that's
some ways of manipulating data to prove
to push an agenda not sure how that
analysis was conducted or how that
sampling was pulled
but they are pushing out statistics
everywhere right in marketing
and so in our companies we definitely
want to make sure we use these
principles in a way that we're not
pushing someone's agenda
i've been a part of organizations where
a manager or supervisor and executive
wants to deploy a particular
i.t solution because they like it
and they want to use six sigma to prove
that it should be used uh that's pushing
an agenda
and that's not what we
that's not what we want to do and we'll
we'll walk through uh together as you go
through six sigma training you'll see
the the right way to analyze data and
we'll also show you the wrong way
knowing how not to do it how not to make
the interpretations
but what's critical with lean six sigma
that it is a data-driven decision-making
process using data correctly
and so what's interesting is when we get
when we talk about data in a company
some companies have a lot of data that's
used and some don't use the data right
and what we want to do is get you from
one piece of this to the other
we want to get you to the data driven
section
so wherever you find yourself in the
spectrum if your organization yourself
is in data denial which means you just
trust data and avoid using it
your data indifferent you don't care
about data and have no need for it
or your data informed which means you
only use it when it supports your
opinions or decisions wherever you find
yourself in that spectrum of using data
will be critical to unlocking
productivity for you and your
organization is to use data be data
driven use it to shape and inform all
your decisions
is what we want that's what we would
like to see
so i i have seen one question come up
already and i want to address this
question
so it says what is a six sigma champion
right so that's a term you've heard
there are many different roles in six
sigma and so a six sigma champion is an
individual who
who pushes if you will who is a
cheerleader within the organization to
make sure holistically that everyone is
using six sigma right because six sigma
is a top-down approach
uh organizations are made up of
different departments different leaders
some may get on board a little bit more
slowly using six sigma than others right
but the champion is encouraging that the
entire organization the entire company
starts using the six sigma tools and
techniques
making sure that they have the resources
they need the training that's necessary
to do that the champion also helps line
up or queue up six sigma initiatives and
projects
right so you can think of a six sigma
champion as the individual normally an
executive within the company and that is
pushing for six sigma use
so another question that i see
so it's got a lean six sigma be applied
to all aspects of industries or only
manufacturing
yet and that's this is the great thing
about lean six sigma now lean six sigma
definitely had its start in more
manufacturing environments but what has
been proven from my experience lean six
sigma
applies to any industry any industry the
key the challenge in applying it however
is that when using lean six sigma you
have to have a clear understanding of
what the customer's requirement is
if we can identify the customer
requirement and we can define what
a defect is right like in our example
the customer requirement was having a
cup of coffee with a cup of coffee with
a certain temperature we can define what
that is and measure it we can use lean
six sigma
that is something that is taught and
should be explained more right to many
individuals
is that there are some projects or some
initiatives that should be lean six
sigma and there are some that should not
use lean six sigma are there certain
elements that should be there that's not
something we're going to get into the
details here today but yes lean six
seven can definitely be applied to any
industry as long as we can understand
what our customers needs are and define
our process have a
problem in form of a defect then we can
use these tools to fix things
uh principle number four and this is our
the last principle and this is the one
that i
i like to talk about
a lot is that principle number four uh
to be successful to use lean six much a
lot productivity
productivity can only be locked uh by
being a change agent and so
even though we're talking about the keys
of lean six symbols the techniques right
the methodology a lot of it's going to
have to be uh
a lot of it is attributed to the
individuals the six sigma the lean
success practitioners and being a change
agent is very critical and i'll explain
why of how if we want to unlock
productivity in our companies
now this illustration that you're seeing
here are different skill sets right
these different circles so and these are
all what makes a change agent and so
some individuals are great number
crunchers right they're good at pulling
data they're great statistical analysis
it's perfect they can do a regression
analysis hypothesis testing they can
calculate standard deviation and
averages and tell you the trends and
that's one aspect of being a change
agent uh some individuals are great with
the business acumen they understand
revenue and cost and they can see
opportunities
right from a business side
we have others that are great with
political skills right they're great
communicators good orators they can
encourage and get people excited and so
when we look at some of these where they
enter when they change and cross over
for instance if we have someone who's a
great number cruncher
right you might see them as uh and
they're understanding the business
acumen
they might be considered like a business
analyst or they just analyze the data
there's nothing wrong with that rule
that's a perfect rule every company we
need are analysts uh but
an analyst in itself using the skills of
lean six sigma that will not unlock any
productivity right we have data that we
looked at we see root causes we see
trends but nothing was changed within
the company or the organization we
didn't make the process better if we're
not taking our data and driving change
and leading how are we unlocking
productivity we're not we're just
providing information and so that's
another reason why being a change agent
is critical if we have the business
acumen and we have the political skills
we can be seen as a leader
but what are we leading individuals to
that's the question we're relating them
to our own agenda or we're leading them
to the root cause of the problem right
we're leading them to fix the right
issues so we can have that leadership
component but without the data
where are we going that's the question
where are we headed
so that
leadership in itself is not enough
to unlock this productivity and this
last piece up here having the political
skills and the number cruncher will be
more of just a siren we'll be sharing
everyone what the problem is and we'll
be able to communicate the problem but
without that business piece uh we're
just sounding the alarm right this is
the issue this is our issue but we need
all of these three components together
to enact change in the organization to
unlock that productivity so we can have
all the techniques down look at all the
methods down of lean six sigma
right but without having those change
agents within your company without being
one yourself
there's nothing that we really
accomplish
nothing
breakthrough
nothing significant as far as that
process improvement so being a change
agent is critical and not all of us are
are born with these skill sets we have
to learn it we have to have that
experience right to get there be
mentored to get there
but this is the critical key to
unlocking productivity
so this is a funny illustration that i
found about being the changing and
there's a lot of tools that we have
right there one thing about being a
change agent is one of those terms
that's used a lot in
in industries now in different markets
and companies and there's a lot of tools
that we have whether it's our data
analysis
here this change agent has the carrot
approach
versus the stick no rewards and
incentives has this knowledge
a lot of different things here when
you're changing it almost feels like
you're a superhero or a hero within the
company
but what i like about this is that we're
all capable of being change agents
i just need the right training
that right push
and we can all in that change we can all
learn to do this
now
what's good is that there's different
styles of being a change agent not every
change looks the same or operates the
same way and it really is going to
depend on you know company culture on
your regional culture and a lot of it
has to do on the environment of what
that changing it could look like and
what look like the one on the left
there's different types of leadership
styles
i know a lot of individuals like the
type of leadership style when they talk
about
a leader gets down in there in the
trenches with you the leader helps
so in this case this may not be an ideal
leadership scenario for a lot of
individuals all right where the leader
is on top of the arrow everyone else is
lifting but the leader is at least
pointing the direction and some cultures
they like the leader to be down there
holding the arrow with everybody else
you know the change agent and other
cultures this is what is expected the
leader to
be pointing the way and focusing efforts
on figuring out what's wrong and giving
up providing solutions and
recommendations that's what's desired
and so we can't say there's one type of
change agent that's going to fit every
scenario
right there's different variations of
being a change agent but those three
principles always remain the same you
need the business acumen we need the
leadership or the political capability
and also the number cruncher but it
could manifest itself or it can be seen
differently
that's why the illustration on the left
on the right is here is that this these
change agents can come in different
shapes and
sizes so now everyone look the same and
that's good and i want you to know that
before we end today's webinar as we're
walking through these things
is that you don't have to fit a certain
mold right just make sure that we're
going to have understand how to crunch
the numbers
work on those communication skills and
also
understand the business
and your own personality will play a
huge role in your change agent style and
every company needs different types of
change agents to enact the change
necessary and unlock that productivity
and so you may be wondering well uh with
six sigma there's this uh there's a lot
going on how how do i do this
uh especially with the statistical
analysis component so here this is a
illustration a graph showing the
important factors for a lean success
practitioner it's typical right
overcoming obstacles
is roughly like 34
of what's needed from a skill set
perspective the attitude over 25 percent
logical thought process
communication skills 9
and then down here we see where a lot of
people when i think of lean six sigma
they think of these elements here the
data interpretation availability the
mathematical skills
those are on the lower end
of what we require of what's needed to
be a successful lean successful
practitioner
right and the reason for that there's
many different reasons the reason for
that is that i mean
there's a ton of statistical software
packages out nowadays that are going to
run and crunch the numbers for you now
you will have to understand what the
results are telling you right what that
direction you should go based off the
interpretation
but you're not required to memorize a
lot of the formulas or understand the
ins and outs of regression analysis
to be successful
and that goes under that number cruncher
category that yes over the years with
time and experience and training you'll
become more and more
knowledgeable on the statistical side of
the house but to unlock productivity in
your organization that is not critical
all right what's critical is that
mindset to overcome obstacles that
attitude that that can go get things
done right that wants to bring people
together and get them excited about
enacting change in their organization
so the takeaway here is that a degree in
math or phd in statistics is not
required to be a lean six sigma change
agent
so either you're an agent of change or
you're destined to become a victim of
change
you simply can't survive over the long
term if you insist on standing still
and that's a quote from a norm brodsky
he's an entrepreneur
i always like that that quote on being a
change agent
and so i always
encourage everyone when i try to teach
at a seminar or webinar
at the end to choose to be a change
agent today so whether you are
considering to learn more about lean six
sigma
that's good that's a good step i want
you to learn those tools about unlocking
productivity for your organization but
also learn about being a change agent
that complete package as well it's not
just about the tools and techniques but
about how we lead how we guide how we
encourage others those around us and for
those of you that are acting and change
agents and i want to thank you all for
what you're doing in your organizations
i always believe that quality impacts
all of us so the quality the
improvements that we're giving in each
of our organizations give us all a
better outlook on life right improves
everything it makes our world more
productive more productive so i am
important for you all to be a change
agent today
so our conclusion is how six sigma makes
us more productive
or how it unlocks the key to unlocking
productivity is based off those four
principles
it focuses on quality number one number
two follows the process called demand
three adheres to data driven decisions
and then four being a change agent is
critical
to unlocking the productivity uh that's
already there in our processes in our
organizations but this is our conclusion
and what we're going to do now as i
wanted to go through are the questions
that you have uh presented
thank you for these questions i i love
answering them and engaging with you so
one of the questions that we have here
so with the time left we'll kind of walk
through different questions uh what
would you recommend to a beginner to
tackle and and to penetrate his way from
the yellow
all the way to the mbb
i'm going to answer this in two
different ways now from a lean six seven
perspective i know i think yellow belt
and there might be in some cases a white
belt and some organizations that just
focus on lean a yellow belt is just like
a six sigma or lean six segment
information or awareness class
now to start off as a black belt
right the only requirement the only boat
that has a requirement is an mbb a
master black belt
and the requirement is that you have to
be a black belt
for so many years or conduct so many
projects
so there is no prerequisite to being a
black belt you don't have to be a green
belt for so many years or a yellow belt
if you like you're able to go straight
to black belt training uh if you feel
that you're ready for that if you
already have some statistical knowledge
and background that your ramp up won't
be too difficult that's fine many
individuals will start with the green
belt class first because it's an
introduction they learn some of the
basic statistics get some experience
there then they go
further to the black belt but there is
no set industry standard prerequisite
that you have to do a green belt before
a black belt but it is highly
recommended
it's my recommendation if that's what
you want to do and it depends on your
company culture if you have a company
that has a lean six sigma uh culture set
in place you're already going to have a
mentor
but the recommendation i would have if
you want to shoot your way up if you
caught the way you're trying to
penetrate your way up to a master black
belt find a mentor find someone who is a
master black belt already and have them
guide you and train you whether that's
within your own organization or someone
outside of your organization i join
quality groups whether it's asq
things of that nature and link up
network with other master black belts
and have them mentor you and kind of
walk you through the journey
another question is is six sigma
approach really helpful in every
industry how
should we apply the demand principle
i would say six sigma approach is really
helpful in every industry and again on
that guys i want us to to think about
it's applicable to every industry but
not applicable to every type of problem
it depends on the type of problem they
have to be able to identify what the
customer's needs are but we can't
clearly identify the customer
requirement it's going to be hard to use
the tools of lean six sigma because it's
all focused on what the customer's needs
are
so as long as our problem can do that
there'll be some other things uh that
needs to be looked at from a problem
standpoint
so it's not really about industry
specific it's more of problem type
specific
and here the other part of the question
was how to apply the domain principle
right so with the make there's going to
be certain set of tools that are used i
know at a high level we talked about
define measure analyze improvement
control uh if you're taking or you're
going through the six sigma lean six
sigma training uh we'll we'll teach you
we'll show you what are the tools and
techniques that to be used in the domain
or the defined process what is the
deliverable the objective right the
outcome so it's going to walk you step
by step on how to apply that principle
which unfortunately is not something
that we have time for today but that's
how each of those phases
is going to have a set of tools that are
going and techniques used
so another question that came up is does
kaizen fall into this model too
yes it does
kaizen falls into the model it's part of
the it's one of the things on the
umbrella more on the lean side right for
those of you familiar with the term
kaizen this is a japanese term that
means like change for the better or
improvement quick change
kaizen has many different
translations but all of them are correct
kaizen is a a broad term about improving
our processes
so kaisen principles do fall into this
and in some cases the way i've been
taught about even
doing kaizen
normally a kaizen event is we bring
everyone together all the stakeholders
to focus on an issue and we focus on
that issue and we're talking about a
kaizen event here we focus on that issue
for a week or three days or how long it
takes to make some rapid change occur
and so i've heard it say that kaizen is
like uh domaic on steroids in a way
where we go through the domain cycle but
we do it within a week with a group and
a team there and so there are they are
all related uh kaizen is also a cultural
approach but it is a part of this
overall concept it does fit
in there
particularly on the lean side we'll talk
about lean six sigma
so another question is what is the
prerequisite for a lean six sigma
certification
awesome awesome question so for if
you're going for a yellow belt
or a
a black all right not black well a
yellow bull or green belt the
prerequisite from an industry standard
or across industry just accepted in the
marketplace it's just to take
or i should say just to pass the exam
right not even to take training if you
don't need it if you can
pass an exam then you can be certified
now for black belt what's needed is you
have to work a project and pass an exam
to show competency to be a certified
six sigma black belt
and for that master black belt
that's just you have to be a black belt
for many years working projects and then
you have to take a different exam and
show your project results like a project
portfolio for a master black build
that's just accepted now different
companies may do
handle their program slightly
differently i know when i got my green
belt certification i was required to
work a project but that was because i
was certifying through that company
but across the industry typically a
project for a green belt is not required
but one is required for a black belt
and speaking of that leads to the next
question
this question says may i please know the
exact difference between a green belt
and a black belt
absolutely so what we're looking at here
are several factors
a green belt is typically a part-time
role within the organization at least a
part-time quality role normally someone
who's trained as a greenbelt they'll
still complete and conduct their normal
day-to-day activities but on occasion
they'll lead a six sigma project or
they'll even partner and help a six
sigma black belt on a project
so they kind of do two different
functions here the normal day in and day
out activities if they're a coder for
instance they'll code half the day or
you know not literally but just as an
illustration the code half the day and
then the other half of the day they'll
work a project
or they'll help a black belt work
another project
a black belt is a full-time role so
that's all a black belt will be doing is
working projects so a question comes up
is what is your career goal if you
really enjoy what you're doing maybe you
don't want to operate as a black belt
you want to operate as a green boat
right means you do
the role part time
now a certification of course does not
define your role i've known individuals
who are certified black belts or master
black belts that don't even they have
they have that certification but they
operate as an operational person if you
will they do day
day-to-day activities whether they're a
coder or patient registration
they just have that tool
uh that tool set underneath their belt
but they could go for a position that's
a full-time role in those areas and so
from a training perspective the black
belt has more statistical knowledge than
the green bow it goes through more
advanced statistical tools uh go through
more
training and experience on leadership
and so those are some of the main
differences from a project perspective
greenbelt projects are typically
expected only to bring in like a
financial benefit of 50 000 a year uh
black belt projects are expected to
impact the company with 200 000
a year in financial benefit on their
projects so larger in scope
so another question that we have here so
in the it service desk how does lean six
sigma help in productivity and how to
apply the techniques yep so we're
talking about a service decks this is a
great example of using lean six sigma
i've had some ide individuals ask about
you know coding and things of that
nature and it does help it helps but i t
service desk is great because in the ic
service test there's typically a process
that's
followed right in order to get it that
ticket in how do we filter tickets to
the right people you know things of that
nature now as far as coming up to a
solution
you know because i t we're trying to fix
a problem right uh someone's computer
crashed we don't know why uh six sigma
is not going to tell us why the computer
crashed of course right someone with
their expertise
about computer crashes have to go in and
diagnose the computer and figure out
what happened
and so where it's going to help from
productivity standpoint is that there is
a process that's followed right there's
the help desk process where a ticket
gets generated it's sent and what needs
to happen is we make sure that the
ticket gets to the right person quickly
i've been in uh seen some i.t
organizations where they're not clear of
who the ticket should go to right and
there's different reasons why whether
they're not sure what the real issue is
right that could be one reason and they
need to figure out how can we get better
information from our customer which is
probably someone within the business
right who has an i.t issue how can we
get better information the first time so
we can route these tickets correctly and
not have a lot of rework and
re-communication which is extending our
delivery time right
so six sigma lean will be applied there
to find out what what key requirements
do we need what questions would we ask
ahead of time you know those those
things would be used
that will allow us to be more
productivity
more productivity more productive and
that's just one
one aspect there one element there are
several different things
that we that we could do that's a great
question
uh okay someone is curious about what i
was saying earlier now what is the
trigger point for identifying a lean six
sigma project
yep
uh so i'm trying to wrap the top of my
head now there are a couple triggers
uh to identify if a project or if an
issue should be a lean six sigma issue
right now some of the things is right we
need to understand the customer's
requirements
it should be a quality issue that we're
dealing with here
the root cause of the problems should
not be known
because a lot of the tools and
techniques we're using is to help us
drill down to a root cause if we already
know it it should probably just be
something that gets
we just it's a go do project we don't
need the the tools of lean six sigma to
get it done or if the solution is known
already we don't need lean six sigma
either
if we know we need to implement new
system if the equipment is just outdated
all right we don't need lean six sigma
to prove any of that we should just go
get it done
now those are some of the triggers that
tell us if it should or should not be a
lean six sigma project
if we don't know the root cause that's
great we can use lean six sigma that's
perfect opportunity and there are some
other things as well there's not just
one trigger there's actually a couple of
things like a checklist that we would go
through to evaluate the projects
that the entire checklist right with the
questions we have i don't have time to
walk through those checklists but i do
want you to know that you're right there
are certain triggers certain things that
we're looking for
that determines if a project could fit
that six sigma mode model and that it
may not
so the next question is do you i think
that six sigma would be relevant in
government departments which providing
various services to citizens
absolutely yes uh six sigma
and i've talked to different six segment
practitioners that have used it that
have consulted with government uh at
least in their you know their respective
regions and countries to implement
projects to help citizens so there is
benefit there right
all governments could use some help
reducing costs and improving
productivity
and so that
the tools of six sigma
definitely applies from a government
standpoint
uh so the next question is uh how is six
signal useful for retail support
services
so the answer to that question i'd say
is very similar to
some of the other answers so far right
and it is all going to depend on the
problem as long as we have a customer
requirement
we can use uh six sigma but it's going
to depend on the type of problem that we
have
uh oh someone asked a question about
kanban so i see you're familiar with
lean so do we have something for kanban
here in the realm of lean six sigma
absolutely because when we say lean six
sigma which is great in this methodology
productivity we have uh the benefits of
lean ansys and six sigma so for those of
you that are lean trained or know a lot
about leaning all that gets rolled into
the lean six sigma component
now the difference is when we're talking
about lean and six sigma together uh
what we would do
first would do lean so if we're going to
go improve a process or run a project
we'll use the lean tools first remove
the waste from a process and then use
the six sigma tools second
so everything that you know about lean
kanban kaizen those tools will be
utilized first and then we would
transfer over and use some of the six
sigma tools
so how do how does lean six sigma differ
for tqm uh now
tqm total uh quality management
lean six sigma are very similar
now total quality management is a
different technique
that follows a different process
one of the main differences it doesn't
have demaio
and tqm one of the main differences and
there are several other differences
between them but at the end of the day
this is what i would say because i get
questions about uh like this i'm going
to kind of expand this question a little
bit the questions i receive are well why
do you use lean six sigma versus any
other continuous improvement methodology
honestly even though lean six sigma i'm
a huge proponent of it and that i think
it does unlock productivity there are
other continuous improvement tools that
do as well all right i think about even
toyota toyota does not use lean six
sigma toyota still to this day unless
they've changed recently use lean only
right as you may know lee came from
toyota they don't see the need for six
sigma lean works just
for them it's just as just as good for
them it gives them the productivity they
need and so i would my case here is
that as long as there's some continuous
improvement methodology being used right
that's what's important uh here and we
can argue philosophically which one is
better than another things of that
nature from my experience i say as long
as the organization is committed to one
as that top management support to make
it successful that's going to drive
change in an organization
whether that's lean or six sigma or lean
sigma or tqm
but there are some minor differences
between them more of the process
standpoint and their area of focus
so question here yep good observation so
here the question is
sigma is explained in detail
uh but no mention of lean
and why is that
uh really um i think there's really no
uh there's no bias there right i i do
like lean as well it was just based off
of my training and my my experience
right when i work a project i don't
typically work a project from a lean
standpoint i work it following the six
sigma approach but i incorporate lean
tools into it right and that's typically
what happens and you'll see when you
take like a lean six sigma training
class which is very interesting uh lean
tools and concepts are talked about but
it's typically the domain cycle that's
followed when we're using a project so i
tried to use the words when i talked
about it
normally i kind of just truncate the
expression to say six sigma
but i really referring to lean six sigma
so hopefully i was communicating that
with my words uh when i talk about six
sigma it's lean and six sigma that i'm
referring to and not just one
methodology over another uh both are
required when we're talking about lean
six sigma to unlock uh productivity in
an organization
because i believe lean succinit gives us
the efficiency
i mean lean give us the efficiency and
it gives us the effectiveness so we need
both
you